nick is the only guy who got super
famous and stayed exactly the same
exactly the same never changed at all
he's [ __ ] awesome i mean i'd say
brogan too he's a guy who i mean but i
guess i knew him for being famous but
now he's at a different level i told you
i hung out with the same guy it's like
hanging out with a politician yeah
you're just like
oh you have to move different now
because you're so massive you have to
but he's the same he's just surrounded
by different people that look out for
safety and make smart moves like you
just can't
roll around like we do but he's the
exact same exactly he was just on
schultzy's pot because he's doing shows
with joey diaz yeah and tony hinchcliffe
in jersey yeah so he came early and then
came to new york to do schultzy's yeah i
saw him uh new show it's so fun you
gotta get high it's so fun yeah
yeah man it's it's fun too because you
know rogan can i mean he's done find a
kid twice maybe once maybe once and
called in once no we had to go there
oh i'm sorry no so he's done the
infamous that was the infamous
yeah
but that was that's what people forget
that was actually firing a kid
episode it was released on fire in the
kid but we did in joe rogan studio and
you're supposed to be just you and me
you were the one who said i remember we
were like maybe we shouldn't air that
because it went live for but but but
then we were like
the only people that were listening
after we got done you guys are we don't
have to hear this man that we were like
no we're airing it in the air you said
it truth yeah but no but it was huge
yeah it was huge yeah it used to be
roman's biggest pot and then elon musk
said
hold my
blunt yeah and let me take it from here
yeah man that was the biggest thing
ever and you you were like let's just
air it yeah it was a tough one so that
we did that that was fine the kid and
then remember when we were at fox
remember we were like in an office
building yep and he called in because i
forget who i'd be yeah i know and i go
dude how the [ __ ] have you not done the
podcast i'm going to do it if i win you
got to do this yeah i'll do it dude but
then he called in remember that well
because and it was after you had beaten
matt matrion
and that's right and he was like yeah i
remember that that's right but it's it's
like he'll do
you know you didn't know joe then you're
like joe where's that we were cool
because i knew him from denver right but
we were never like as close as we are
now but i was like what are you doing
dude you're so critical on that material
thing he goes yeah well guess what
mitchell is a huge threat on his feet so
you know yeah i choked him out okay cool
yeah so yeah he's never been in the
studio with us but it's because he
doesn't do a lot of i'm trying to think
he did like what ben shapiro's or some
some of those other guys pods every now
and then yeah very rare but very rarely
yeah and then him on other people's pods
fun because like with schulte right he
has the whole flagrant two crew with
akash and all the boys there and they're
just you know they're wild [ __ ] so
they're shooting from the hip and you
know rogan doesn't like you know
schultzy his new studio is ridiculous
put all this money into it it's like
state of the art and wrong goes oh
you've complicated you may you've done
too much like this is this not how it's
supposed to be and i bet they thought he
was incoming like oh this is nice but
you know rogan he's like what are you
doing it's too much like wait what you
know rogan's just like you've over
complicated it like podcast champions
right like in a weird way so part of
what makes podcasts and
anything that you see content that
people really like
the minute you start turning it into a
very
high-end production it's really
interesting people tend to go i don't
know like they can't they go i now i'm
watching a show and it's not as it's not
as outlaws it's not as gritty so it's a
big no it depends on the talent because
schulte has done that and he's still
he's still true to himself and so is
akash but then you know there's there's
different by the way i'm just going to
say this out loud if he [ __ ] said
game of thrones if he comes to la and he
doesn't do our podcast after he did that
i'm going to fight him i'm finally going
to fight him you guys always want to
know who's going to win you're going to
find out yeah he comes there then me and
him are fighting yeah i'm going to be so
there's that i'll take it personally
yeah oh we'll tag team them yeah but um
yeah so with it it is interesting
because originally podcasts right
especially when rogan started or marin
or corolla it was very meat and potatoes
but now you're talking about a different
there's argument for both you're talking
about a different game because you look
at like your mom's house with sugar that
thing is highly produced it's a mini tv
show
massive you look at king of the sting
king the sting dude that's a
i would say it's the same production
level as like part of my take on espn
that thing's a monster yeah we have to
have outside editors you got graphics
you got submission videos like it's a
beast intro outros like it's a beast
several different
video you'll gameplay people like uh
armchair expert no video mark man no
video there's no hypothetical video on
those no
wow i think call of daddy might have
video now because when there are
barstool she did maybe now that she's on
spotify because they've added videos
she's on there but yeah aren't your
expert marc maron corolla like you know
those guys are audio first and
monsters yeah but then there's you know
there's different ones like pens right
yeah i mean you look at again you look
at cigar stuff or a lot of these other
people they're
i mean you're talking about a real
production man yeah okay like kane is
sting dude we have to shoot that on
tuesday and it's i'm telling you it
drops thursday nights at like 9 00 p.m
the editor and the people that go into
the production
it's till the
[ __ ] second to get it out i don't get
the audio until like freaking 8 30 8
o'clock yeah because it's like right on
the water there's there's so many moving
parts in that show and it's the most
expensive show to make like it's not
cheap man [ __ ] yeah because so much goes
into it i'm i'm editing my special right
now you're doing it yourself when i have
an editor okay it's a beast because i'm
there yeah i'm there it's the worst it's
i [ __ ] hate it i hate watching myself
i hate everything about it and i
captured a lot of what i wanted to do
but um it's it's it's the worst have you
have you thought of have you have you
thought how long you're going to do it
yeah so so like that's the problem it
could be i could put out a strong 50
minutes that might be a little long i'd
like to put out a 40 minute special so i
might do that the tighter 40s probably
you might do it but you got to kill a
lot of your babies but then i can take a
lot of those bits and let them live on
their own